à peine annexer déjà évacué l'armée
russe en aide perte de vitesse depuis
l'été reculent encore dans la région de
rerson que Moscou a unilatéralement
annexé en début de mois la Russie évacue
la population vers le sud
à la suite de l'appel du chef de la
région de Herson de la Fédération de
Russie Vladimir saldo le gouvernement a
décidé d'organiser une aide pour le
départ des habitants de la région vers
d'autres régions du pays
nous fournirons à chacun un logement
gratuit ainsi que tout le nécessaire
ceux qui décideront de rester
définitivement se verront attribuer un
logement
5 localités auraient été reprise par
l'armée ukrainienne malgré les forts
bombardements de Moscou dans la région
quant aux frappes massive russe sur
l'ensemble du pays cette semaine malgré
la destruction de quelques
infrastructures elles n'ont pas permis
d'inverser le rapport de force
on éparpillant seulement une partie de
la poudre
montre qu'ils ont fui très vite
nous avons son lentement mais c'est
mieux comme ça
on aurait beaucoup de pertes
côté rue son tente de regagner la
bataille de l'image avec entre autres
ces volontaires bien équipées filmées
dans la région deux aporidga mais au
moins tant que les centaines de milliers
de réservistes mobilisés par Moscou ne
seront pas opérationnels rien ne semble
pouvoir interrompre la dynamique de
l'armée ukrainienne